-Hey, the big game
was last night, Super Bowl.
Did you watch the Super Bowl?
-Super what?
[ Laughter ]
-Do you care about football
at all, the Super Bowl?
-I know nothing about football,
nor do I care to find out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You brought a game
for me tonight, though.
You know I enjoy games.
Thank you for doing this.
-You do?
-Yeah. You knew that.
-Okay, look, you're always
doing the games.
Sit here.
I'll sit there.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I always wanted to do that.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
Was it easier than you thought?
-This is really good.
-Yeah.
-Look, you always play games,
and --
-Are you gonna wear
your glasses?
Oh, I can wear them?
You look good in glasses.
-I wanted
to turn it around this time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So I thought I'd quiz you
a little bit on your knowledge
of the German language.
[ Laughter ]
-It's up there with yours
and football, I think.
[ Laughter ]
So I wanted to test your
knowledge on long German words.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This is
a big hit show in Germany.
"Long German Words."
[ Laughter ]
-You go, "Welcome back," and the
crowd goes, "Long German Words!"
[ Laughter ]
-"Longer! Longer! Longer!"
-Yeah.
-So, sitzpinkler.
I'll give you multiple choices.
The urge to steal things or make
loud noises when intoxicated.
Or B,
a man who pees sitting down.
[ Laughter ]
-"Sit pincha"?
-Sitzpinkler.
-"Se pinkla."
I would say, uh...
Although sitting down peeing
is an enjoyable thing.
I would say it is A, of course.
-No, it isn't.
[ Buzzer ]
Sorry.
-It's not?
-No, it's a man
sitting down peeing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next word, next word.
Come on.
-Longer!
[ Audience chants "Longer" ]
-Longer! Longer! Longer!
♪♪ Um-pah, um-pah ♪♪
Go like, "Um-pah."
Here we go, longer.
-Waldeinsamkeit.
[ Laughter ]
-"Halt izumkite."
So A, the experience
of wandering around
alone in the forest
and being overcome with a sense
of woodland solitude.
[ Laughter ]
Or...
Or B, the overwhelming urge
to build a wall
even when it does not seem like
a reasonable thing to do.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What is the word again?
-Waldeinsamkeit.
It's a beautiful word.
-A?
-Correct.
-A man who wanders
around the woods and finds --
[ Ding! ]
-Very good. Very good.
Bravo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Third word.
-All right, here we go.
Longer! Longer.
[ Audience chants "Longer" ]
-Bezirkschornsteinfegermeister.
[ Laughter ]
-A, the head chimney sweep
of the governing district,
or B, the experience
of seeing someone
who looks pretty from behind
but not from the front.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you say the word --
the words again?
-Bezirkschornsteinfegermeister.
[ Laughter ]
-The answer is -- drumroll.
[ Drumroll ]
B!
-No.
-Yes!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
Why would I guess that?
-It actually is the head chimney
sweep of the governing district.
-But the German words were
longer than the actual words
of the definition.
That's what screwed me up
on that one.
Thank you
for playing that with me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for always
playing fun games with us.
-That's pretty good.
Pretty good.
-I always want to learn,
so, yeah, thank you for this.
-And there's ample scope.
-I want everyone to know
about this movie, "Alita."
This is "Battle Angel."
And this is -- I've never seen
anything like this type of film.
I don't know
if you saw the trailer for it,
but it's in the future.
There's this little girl,
and she has like --
I don't know how
they do it with graphics,
but how much
of her face is real?
-Well, it is real,
but it is enhanced reality.
In all seriousness, it is.
-I've never
seen anything like it.
seen anything like it,
I've never
done anything like it,
and it is an experience
that you most likely
will not have had
ever in your life before.
It works
on an intellectual level.
It works on an emotional level.
It's a love story,
an adventure story.
Action, violence.
You know?
-It's mind-bending.
I would go see it in IMAX or 3-D
if I had the option.
-Well, and you do.
-Yeah. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
I'll go see it again
in IMAX is what I would do.
-Can we go together?
-Yeah, we can totally
go together, yeah, absolutely.
-Speak German.
-We'll make it a
vishinvashincushinvishin.
Yeah.